el gobierno británico confío en que
tendrán las vacunas necesarias para
continuar con su plan de inmunización de
15 billones de personas las más
vulnerables para el 15 de febrero esto
ante el temor de que no recibiría las
vacunas en el tiempo estipulado tratando
de limar las asperezas entre londres
dublín bruselas y belfast el ministro
británico del gabinete michael gov dijo
que fue un error de la unión europea
sobre las vacunas esto después de más de
24 horas frenéticas en las que la unión
europea revocó su decisión de suspender
temporalmente el acuerdo
bracey imponiendo entonces controles
físicos entre las irlandas para evitar
que las vacunas manufacturadas en su
territorio llegarán al reino unido a
través de irlanda del norte esto provocó
por supuesto furia en belfast en dublín
y en londres y también se sabe que en
algunos mandatarios de la unión europea
porque desde
acuerdo de paz de 1998 esta frontera
invisible no ha estado vigilada y ha
sido muy importante
irlanda del norte en los años de la
negociación del break sí porque lo que
se quiere evitar es que los motivos que
causaron este conflicto en las irlandas
sean revividos por ahora londres y
bruselas han acordado que este impasse
ha sido superado pero no hay certeza de
que sea un tema recurrente más adelante